yes it all comes down to risk and
bennett benefit now clearly uh
older people are at much higher risk of
dying from covid for them
they can take the risk of of a blood
clot because it is still
extremely rare just four in a million or
so
so the the risk of covert is much much
higher but of course younger people
those in their 20s the risks of
dying are very low indeed and that is
why
the jcvi the joint committee on
vaccination and
immunization has taken the view that for
people
aged between 18 and 29 that they should
be
offered an alternative vaccine either
pfizer or the moderna vaccine now being
rolled out in wales from today and
elsewhere in the uk and in the coming
weeks there are going to be several
million doses of those so
they will be offered an alternative
because so far there is no safety signal
associated with those rna vaccines it's
a different kind of technology
to the oxford astrazeneca one and that's
why they're taking the precautionary
approach and for these young people
whether benefits of vaccination are
lower
that they also have to reduce the risk
and that means giving these alternative
vaccines
not astrazeneca what do we know thomas
you were just talking about there
talking there about the number of
vaccines we've got the different types
of vaccine we had moderna coming on
stream today
we have been warned that there's going
to be disruption in supply to
the vaccine programme this month that
cohort that we're talking about
the bulk of which won't expect to be
seeing their first jabs
until towards the summer what do we
think it could mean
for the progress of the vaccine program
well certainly there's potential that it
will be delayed by a few
weeks and yes these people in their 20s
would have been
the last to receive the vaccinations
because
we're still going down the age bands
over over the weeks now there's nobody
due to receive their first doses
uh in in april because there's already
been a a supply issue
uh with the vaccines but things will
pick up again from
may and and begin to be rolled out but
you can expect that
the government's target of reaching
everybody by the end of july may now
have to be pushed back in
into august uh if there is is a problem
now
they will i'm sure say that as long as
all the pharmaceutical companies
are able to deliver their doses on time
then then they should be okay because
there will be
other vaccines due to come on stream not
least the the one from
johnson and johnson which is a single
dose but also one from novartis
so the medicine cabinet of vaccinations
is going to increase and that will help
certainly to get over this uh this
problem that that does seem to be
emerging
with the astrazeneca jab what about
people who are in that cohort thomas who
may have already had
the first dose of an astrazeneca vaccine
what what then happens
so the thinking is that they should and
we will hear the details in the news
briefing
shortly that they should come forward
still and have their second dose now
whether they would uh in the
circumstances particularly when people
of a similar age who've yet to have
their first dose of being told that they
should be given alternative that will be
a real test of confidence in in the
vaccine
but the medical regulator and and the
experts for the government uh do believe
that there is still
good benefit from this vaccine there is
no doubt that
older people should still have the
astrozenica vaccine
if there are lots of doses available
take them because the risk of covid
are so much higher the question is for
these younger people
and i think we need to be very careful
that we we stress that it is in the
young
where the risk perhaps begins to look a
little bit uh
difficult to take given that the
benefits of the vaccination because
people don't
in their twenties don't generally die
from the vaccine if they're otherwise
from the virus unless they have an
underlying health condition
they're only being asked to take it to
stop the spread of the virus to the
general population
now that risk trade-off um certainly
becomes
very uh poignant doesn't it when you
think about it like that for the people
in the younger cohorts
what we were hearing from the ema there
was that they hadn't yet
identified any particular risk factor
associated with gender
or with age so are we just to presume
that the investigations are still
ongoing and this is really just a
precaution
it is a precaution and they don't really
understand what's going on they have
found some
evidence of antibodies in the blood that
are associated with other clotting
disorders now is that an
immunological consequence of vaccination
we don't know but it is a possible uh
causative link with the vaccine and
that's why people are being
extremely cautious and certainly we've
heard from the german authorities
that there is this association uh with
young women
and as a precaution they the french the
germans they've all
uh and the canadians rather they've all
taken the view
that uh just to be sure just to be safe
they are not going to give the
astrazeneca people even to the the
middle age now here in the uk the
decision has been
uh to set the bar at a lower age band at
the age of
of 30. so um that is it is definitely
a split if you like within europe on
on the evidence and just what action
they need to take